[Musique]
alors bonjour la planète et si le canada
ici montréal ici radio canada
international en direct du studio 26
dans les donjons de nos opérations
quelque part enfoncé dans un studio ici
en plein sous sol mais c'est parce que
le soleil nous ferait fondre comme de la
neige vous rappelez vous en ayez
canadien où on n'est pas ici stéphane
parent nous voici mais attends images
studio s'il vous plaît parce qu'on est
très beau on veut se voir on veut que
nous voyez alors aller ce bonjour
bonjour stéphane bonjour la planète
voilà c'est un beauty démission c'est
bonsoir la planète je pense c'est radio
france internationale qui fait cette
émission je crois que oui
donc on a un peu joué sur le titre ça
leur appartient
il ne passe pas il nous manque un petit
joueur arrivé à un moment à l'autre
maintenant qu amaury de la section
anglaise
j'allais dire ce n'est les anglais sont
le partage non pas du tout du tout pas
du tout il y en a qu'un seul il faut pas
généraliser non et aujourd'hui à
l'émission il ne faudra pas généraliser
il faudra être sérieux à la fois avoir
du plaisir en simple de découvrir des
choses que ne connut qui ne sont pas
celles que nous connaissons mal et l'âge
on peut parler ici de nous ici comme
simple citoyen canadien on n'était pas
au courant qu'ils avaient des problèmes
entre les ouates si lointaine les gens
qui appartiennent à une communauté en
colombie-britannique voilà qui
s'opposent à un projet de pipeline
voilà puis ces projets de gazoducs que
c'est pas une affaire nouvelle si on
suivait les nouvelles on l'a fait c'est
ce jour que le blocage continue sur les
voies les principales voies ferrées au
canada et la chicane économiques
importants importante
ça fait un bon bout de temps que c'est
chose se tramait si vous lisez les
journaux canada fait il y avait des
négociations depuis longtemps et puis on
y on y portait peut-être pas attention
c'est le résultat c'est que moi je vais
pas commencer à tout expliqué on a un
invité remarquable aujourd'hui pour nous
parler de ça c'est un avocat comme si
les choses n'étaient pas assez compliqué
on invite un avocat mais un avocat en
droit de dire pourquoi ça coince
voilà regardez ces images pour ceux qui
n'étaient pas au courant qu'ils ne
regardent peut-être je ne sais pas moi
au chili
au maroc vous ne saviez pas qu'il y
avait une crise entre une communauté
amérindienne du nord lacombe britannique
et puis les autorités à la fois
policière et puis les autorités
politiques et aussi le monde économique
canadien et puis des jeunes canadiens
aussi qui passe sans s'immiscer dans
cette cause là mais qui savait ccd des
militants pro environnementalistes si
vous voulez et donc une partie il
contribuer au blocus du côté de saint
lambert au québec ça c'est au québec
mais voilà autre endroit au canada où il
ya à différents endroits surtout au sein
des communautés mois qu en ontario et au
québec la mobilisation ne désemplit pas
d'accord
merci pour ce résumé je suis sûr qu'on a
oublié beaucoup de détails et c'est pour
ça qu'on a trente minutes devant nous
pour pour remplir les missions et puis
vous vous expliquer tout ce qui se passe
bonjour madame harel je suis venu vous
êtes venus enfin enfin noires kate est
un de ceux qui a radio canada
international connaît bien le dossier
dont nous allons parler aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça qu'on l'a invité à
l'émission mais félicitations
merci d'être venus alors maintenant on
vous fait pas l'accolade ont fait ce que
vous serrez la main de tarim a peur et
puis je voulais tout de suite vous savez
on a du plaisir quand même en semaine
sur par deux choses sérieuses on a le
premier jeu de la grosse boule
aujourd'hui juste atteint 20 bout la
perle ben oui atteint nous est arrivé à
temps alors premier jeu le 20 boules à
perdre on va afficher la question avant
oui ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez du
mouvement haydn dont moi un stock l
année là vous êtes bon ça fait quand
même
mozilla quatre ans
trois ans avant c'est un peu moi
pensaient peut-être six ans bah écoutez
les années passent vite vous avez raison
mais c'était en 2012 2013 en 2012 fin
2012 début 2013
et puis on va vous montrer après un peu
avant la question montrons les images de
2012 ça ressemble beaucoup aux images de
2000 2020 c'est un soulèvement
amérindiens populaire en raison d'une
nouvelle loi fédérale qui allait enlever
une façon de négocier ou avec des
amérindiens de reconnaître certains
pouvoirs voile elle décerne à toronto
les disons qu'il ya peut-être moins de
gens aujourd'hui qui ont manifesté un
dimanche par exemple à toronto dans la
crise actuelle
mais à l'époque on allait aussi devant
le parlement à ça ressemble beaucoup à
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est sûr
qu'il ya une certaine similitude parce
que non le mouvement d'aujourd'hui il ya
toutes sortes de personnes qui se mêle à
la cause
voilà comme je disais tantôt on a en a
deux jeunes on a de jeunes étudiants
aussi de gênes milena rio qui sont du
côté de saint lambert et qui participent
à ce mouvement citoyen contre ce projet
de danse et l'envers c'est tout c'est au
sud de montréal et la rive-sud de
montréal banlieue mettons tout à fait et
on a vu des policiers à intervenir hier
pour leur servir les gens consomment une
espèce d'injonction obtenu par le
canadien national du côté
des autorités judiciaires qu'il croisera
donc en raison de cette injonction là
les manifestants devraient en principe
libérer les lieux
sauf que il ans comme une espèce de défi
au policier sur place soit se répète en
plusieurs coins du canada depuis deux
semaines premier tour de la grosse boule
voici finalement notre question après
avoir mis la table à même sans manger
ensemble
voici la question les actions des quels
groupes ont déclenché en 2012 donc moi
que le mouvement ado nos amours haider
ne mangeait des difficultés à dire c'est
un anglais français se serait jamais
plus l'inaction pour moi c'est pas la
réponse 1
parce que là le a4 et chef spirituel non
non parce qu'aujourd'hui on parle de 4
chef héréditaire ou dans la cause de
2020 donc le à bangui minet d'office
c'est sa seule c'est votre logique
d'accord c'est ma logique à ce que c'est
mais quatre agents de la grc qui sont à
l'origine de cette révolution
l'amérindienne je dirais est-ce que
c'est ses 84 ans ce qui s'est passé je
suis sûr féminine nous quoi là que ça
dépend à qui tu veux dire par là
déclenché à quel moment là il c'est la
crise d'un dans une réserve en
particulier aussi c'est la réaction du
gouvernement qui est déclenché les
révolutions les guerres sont déclenchées
par un coup de feu part quelque chose
d'accord quel a été l'élément
déclencheur est ce que c'était une
manifestation de quatre agents sous chef
spirituel
quatre agents de la grc quatre femmes
amérindiennes qui ont manifesté je ne
sais pas où quatre ministres du
gouvernement qui aurait posé un geste ni
approprié cette fois la sonde a fini
hors d'affairé généré paix c'est fini
javier
d'accord alors voici la bonne réponse
qui va conserver ses boules devait la
messe si vous conservez vos boules ont
la réponse se fait attendre mais c'est
pour avoir plus plaisir
j'ai changé ma réponse j'étais plus dans
les temps et ça coûte
ben oui ça compte on va être généreux
avec vous vous conservez vos points
samir la compétition je pense bien sûr
alors fini le plaisir en maintenant ses
intérêts c'est en cet éco choses
sérieuses on va essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe on va ici parce allez
découvrir des affaires je pense qu'on a
la bonne personne pour le faire en
entrevue aujourd'hui sur skype m nadir
andric et avocats en droit autochtone au
cabinet blg à montréal monsieur m andré
bonjour écouter sans révéler trop de
secrets professionnels j'ai eu
l'occasion depuis le dites vous suivent
à la trace comme ça à travers le pays
lors de vos bons professionnels vous
êtes un gars très occupé un homme très
occupé
est ce que je sais que je suis un
discret ce que certaines des choses que
vous faisiez cette semaine et est
rattachée à la crise actuelle où vous
êtes quelqu'un façon générale qui vous
occuper d'autres dossiers je ne sais pas
vous pose une question comme ça en
partant le dos et en particulier que
certains de mes clients et d'autres sont
directement touchés par ce qui se passe
présentement confidentialité des
professionnels on se rend on s'entend
là-dessus
alors mettez la table pour nous parlons
d'abord des chefs héréditaire qui sont
au coeur de cette de cette situation
politique économique et sociale tout le
monde ressent l'impact où va le
ressentir si on ne trouve pas une
solution politique est ce qui se passe
actuellement lé chef héréditaire disent
opposés à au tracé à la construction
d'un gazoduc sur un territoire dont il
estime avoir la gestion ou avoir la
responsabilité
qui sont ces gens exactement
et historiquement qui sont ils les chats
créditeurs des watts watten sont des
personnes représentants politiques des
communautés qui exercent une structure
gouvernementale qui est différente de
celle de des conseils de bande
on connaît lieu au canada qui sont des
organismes élu en vertu de la loi sur
les indiens d'agde
comme vous savez probablement il ya 635
réserve indienne au canada en plus de
communautés métier et de communautés
innues est parmi les 635 réserve il ya
donc 635 bande et 635 conseil de bande
certains sont régies par la loi sur les
indiens d'autres sont régies sont régies
par un code électoral coutumier qui
ressemble quand même aux élections la
loi sur les indiens et certaines
communautés ont des structures de
gouvernance parallèle qui remonte à
beaucoup plus longtemps que la loi sur
les indiens
la loi sur les indiens la première
version était adoptée en 1876
alors pour certaines communautés qui
avait une structure de gouvernance
avant la loi sur les indiens certaines
ont conservé cette structure
gouvernementale qui existe toujours
on peut penser au web soit turn on peut
penser aux iroquois moi et mon retard et
jaune au real avec leur système de
langage alors que pour d'autres
communautés
le conseil de bande ont remplacé la
structure traditionnelle qui pouvaient
exister avant la loi sur les cités
youyous à ce moment là un amalgame
l'astuce au gouvernement s'avère un
gouvernement unifié le conseil de bande
et sommet il faut quand même chaque
situation et chaque premières nations
pour
à voir qu'est ce qui existe dans leurs
communautés particulièrement par rapport
à la gouvernance chose qui est certaine
c'est que les gouvernements au canada
que ce soit le gouvernement fédéral où
les gouvernements provinciaux ne
reconnaissent que des conseils devant et
c'est là le coeur du problème
mais est-ce que c'est pas un conflit
pour quand on parle de watsu est une
est-ce que c'est pas un conflit interne
entre les deux camps dans le sens que le
camp de quelques héréditaire compte le
chef élu ça peut paraître comme ça et
peut-être que c'est le cas ou peut-être
que ce n'est pas parce que dans certains
cas le conseil de bande qui est créée en
vertu de la loi sur les indiens point de
vue légal
il exerce une autorité que sur le
territoire de la réserve indienne
l'offre qu'on parle de territoire
ancestral donc on sort de la réserve et
la bunge peux vous dire moi que la loi
sur les indiens ne parle pas du tout
d'une autorité d'un conseil de bande à
l'extérieur de la tête de réseau et donc
laure concentre territoire de réserve
on entre dans une autre catégorie qui
s'appelle les droits ancestraux le titre
indiens et les droits et su prêter et
l'accès sans porter de jugement
personnel je peux vous dire que la
jurisprudence canadienne notamment dans
quelques jugements la colombie
britannique
les tribunaux ont statué que on ne peut
pas présumer que le conseil de bande et
le détenteur légitime des droits
ancestraux d'une communauté c'est une
question de preuves et c'est là que la
gouvernance traditionnels comme celle
des watts soit 1 peut-être pertinents
par rapport à qui détient les droits
collectifs issus de traités droits se
trouvent deux trains indiens au nom de
la collectivité
on ne peut pas présumer que c'est
toujours les conseils de bande qui
détiennent cette légitimité là et c'est
ça qui fait l'objet du débat à l'heure
actuelle alice
oui m on a entendu le premier ministre
du québec que dire ces derniers temps
que le blocage des voies ferrées un peu
partout au pays était illégale
dites moi dans quelle mesure cet art
cette action-là cette activité là et
elle illégale étant donné le droit
légitime des communautés autochtones sur
leurs terres ancestrales bon et c'est un
rond point très important et c'est une
question vraiment de perspectives les
tribunaux canadiens ont reconnu les
droits ancestraux depuis 1990 avec l'art
et sparrow et on reconnaît également le
titre indien dans différents jugements
dont le plus récent qui date de 2014 qui
s'appelle si cantine ou est-ce qu'une
des premières nations de la
colombie-britannique ont réussi à
prouver leur titre autochtone sur leur
territoire
lorsqu'une première nation et ça c'est
la cour suprême qui parle
lorsqu'une première nation dispose le
cidre et trouve son téton titre
autochtone ils ont un droit de veto sur
les développements qui se portent sur
leur territoire et leur consentement est
nécessaire ceux ci il ya un bémol de la
justification de pouvoir porter atteinte
à ses droits là si on a agi de façon en
arabe si on a consulté la population de
façon adéquate à ce moment là le
consentement ne serait pas
nécessairement à dreux qui parce qu'il y
aurait eu des consultations de
l'accommodement fait envers ses
premières nations et dans le cas qui
nous intéresse dans le cas des watts
soit une baisse
il n'ya pas seulement eu consultation et
comment y eut des enfants on appelle
communément des impacts des notaires
grimde 10 des héros en français d
entente sur les répercussions et
avantages ou est ce que la communauté le
conseil de vendre signé des ententes
avec le promoteur est donc le promoteur
présumer que le consentement de la
communauté avait été donné alors il
serait intéressant d'un point de vue
légal
si les chefs héréditaire à l'est devant
les tribunaux puis invoqué le fait que
le consentement était biaisé note
poétique
ni véritablement faudrait voir ce que
les tribunaux amènerait comme comme
décision par rapport à cet enjeu donc
c'est une question que dans la
perspective autochtone les autochtones
ont un titre et qu'on le prouve ou pas
c'est un fait indéniable
alors dans cette perspective le diois
twitter le consentement est requis et
dans ce colloque il s'oppose au projet
tel que présenté dans la perspective
juridique occidental qui t'ont
qu'invoque un droit doit le prouver
alors on se retrouve dans une situation
parce que d'un côté plusieurs la senteur
disait je suis souverain c'est mon
territoire et mon consentement est
requis sur mon territoire je suis le
propriétaire collective de ce territoire
il ne pourra pas y avoir de projet sans
mon consentement
alors que dans la perspective juridique
occidental c'est si vous êtes bord qui
est un droit
vous devez entendre la démonstration et
cette démonstration là et quand même
assez d'ici là bas je voulais avant
d'aller vers le côté politique et là
vous avez à parler d'une solution devant
les tribunaux évidemment ça aurait
faussé pas ça pourrait prendre du temps
là une solution une peau de crise qu'il
faut à laquelle il faut trouver une
solution politique mais j'aurais revenir
un peu en arrière sur cette nation là
sur les citoyens de cette nation là il
ya eu une réunion hier ou avant-hier en
fait dans cette communauté et puis il ya
200 personnes qui sont allées
radio-canada cbi ci a filmé des images
déjà qu'ils se disaient parfois
intimidés d'exprimer leur appui au
projet ou tracé du gazoduc
il ya c'est clair une division au sein
de la communauté et
et on se demande si cette division là
elle n'affaiblit pas la portée de ce que
les amérindiens c'est d'amener à la
table de la négociation s'est jamais une
bonne chose d divisée dans ce cas-ci
quand il ya les gens se sentent
intimidés
c'est encore un peu plus au canada ça
devient c'est bon l'article premier
article lu hier à 6 d'ici sur le web
c'était cette question de division le
point de vue des amérindiens en faveur
du gazoduc quoi dire ces divisions cette
question la question que je vous propose
monsieur c'est la position du
gouvernement est assez difficile
puisqu'on est un société démocratique et
selon un des anciens chefs qui étaient
sept meetings la 85% de watsu et elles
sont en faveur de ce projet là donc
certains claire majorité mais le
gouvernement sera obligé de négocier
avec le minorité des des chefs
traditionnels
est ce que ça ne m'aide pas dans une
situation assez difficile merci je
comprends tout à fait la situation très
délicate dans laquelle entre eux mais
j'aimerais vous rappeler simplement qu à
l'heure actuelle il n'y a pas de
barricade chez les white water la gea
s'est démantelée cette barricade
il n'y a rien qui empêche au projet
d'année de là-bas la problèmatique c'est
l'appui que tu es reçu ailleurs ou
est-ce que là il ya des barricades qui
bloquent des chemins de fer comme vous
savez dans l'attenté de garoua dire le
stick gauche est ailleurs alors d'un
point le jeu c'est que le point focal et
les watts soit parce que c'est ça qui a
déclenché tout ça et là il ya des
conditions il ya des négociations je
comprends totalement la la la la
dynamique qui existe mais encore une
fois si on essaye d'expliquer pourquoi
il ya une crise parce qu'à une minorité
de wet water qui sont en désaccord avec
le projet je pense pas que ça soit
complètement la compréhension didot
aussi ce qui est important de savoir
c'est que les groupes ailleurs
qui semble également être des minorités
appuyé la cause des voitures water dès
maintenant y ait une forme de solidarité
qui fait en sorte que les enjeux sont de
plus en plus difficiles à cerner puis
incluant les solutions
c'est une question non quelque part vous
avez plus de gens qui manifestent dans
les rues de toronto
si on fait le total qui se range
derrière lé chef héréditaire que le
nombre de personnes au niveau du
territoire amérindien qui sont derrière
leur chef et d'eurydice terre c'est une
situation un peu renversante quelque
part pour les dépannages
vous savez la première erreur qu'il
faudrait faire c'est de regarder les
autochtones comme étant un bloc homogène
qui pensent tout de la même façon
premièrement il ya comme dans la société
en général
il ya des personnes qui vont appuyer des
initiatives gouvernementales dans le
secteur de l'industrie alors que
d'autres vont s'y opposer
il ya plein de dossiers qui concernaient
pas les autochtones par exemple des
lignes de transport électrique dans les
laurentides quelques années ou est-ce
que des municipalités s'opposa à signer
deux transpondeurs il ya eu des dib des
démonstrations il ya eu des blocages de
routes etc
même si peut-être d'un point de vue
global les québécois en général était
d'accord avec cette ligne de transport
les personnes les plus touchées
eux sont en désaccord en ce sens que ça
fait partie de la démocratie il faut
vraiment le voir dans cet esprit là non
pas de dire si on sait les attendait le
reconnaît qu il ya d autres acteurs qui
sont plus près des feux l'environnement
appui de leurs droits territoriaux alors
qu'il y en a d'autres qui veulent des
emplois qu'ils veulent ce développement
économique et c'est tout à fait légitime
on sait par ailleurs que les chef
héréditaire ont posé comme condition
pour mettre un terme à cette crise là le
fait que la grc libère les terres qui
sont visés on sait qu'il ya par exemple
la grc a offert de se retirer
sauf que ça ne semble pas faire bush
la vie de ce côté là je sais pas
monsieur legault a proposé qu'on fasse
usage qu'on fasse appel aux forces
policières pour disperser les
manifestants est ce que ce serait une
action légitime premier ministre du
québec
regardez encore une fois c'est une
question qui est prêt improvisé et
personne n'a de boule de cristal
on pourrait très bien appliqué la loi
faire respecter les injonctions qui ont
été octroyés par les différents
tribunaux des différentes juridictions
et peut-être que rien qu'ils pensaient
ou que la réaction serait purement
symbolique et après quelques jours tout
serait rentré dans l'ordre au husa peut
également déclencher une étincelle à
travers le pays dans certaines parties
du pays où est ce qu'il y aura encore
plus de démonstration autochtone ou en
accueil que les autres tomsk oubliez pas
qu il n'y a pas eu d autres soldats y
ont également toutes sortes de groupes
d'intérêts qui participent maintenant
aux manifestations alors ça pourrait
avoir un déclenchement voit ce que l'on
se contentera pas de bloquer des voies
ferrées ça pourrait s'attendre au retour
à d'autres à d'autres choses et ça c
était vraiment c'est très difficile de
pouvoir deviner ce qui se passerait si
si il y avait une action policière
mais rappelez-vous la crise d'oka
rappelez-vous et powell iodé précédent
qui font en sorte qu'elle met pas les
gouvernements sont beaucoup plus plus de
tâches et par ailleurs qu' une étude qui
a été fait il ya pas très longtemps par
un institut qui regardent les politiques
autochtones et sachez que dans 85% des
cas où est-ce que des injonctions sont
demandés par l'industrie les
gouvernements dans 85% des cas les
agents sont accordés alors alors que
lorsque les autochtones vont devant les
tribunaux pour demander des injonctions
pour que des projets ne se réalisent pas
ou soit va tarder c'est moins de 15% qui
leur sont accordées fait que le rapport
de force dans le monde des injonctions
est définie
s'il meurt presque toujours en faveur de
l'industrie des gouvernements m nadir on
se bouscule ici elle attend pour vous
poser des questions ce qui est très bon
signe
g c'est parce que tout le monde on va y
venir c'est la question de la réaction
politique que vous il y avait fait
allusion à l'iss au sujet du premier du
québec françois legault qui a parlé
d'une intervention musclée au niveau
maintenant du 1er mai justin trudeau et
puis du chef de l'opposition un tricheur
on a eu des échos bien différent des
réactions bien différentes
un qui a dit on va prendre le temps de
se parler d'arriver à une solution
consensuelle
voilà et un du chien qui a dit l'europe
le gouvernement y répond avec trop de
mal est là il faut il faut agir
ccc on a le blanc et le noir en plein
dans le visage
c c'est troublant dans la mesure où on
sait quand on a eu des chicanes des
copains on sait qu'il faut se parler il
faut faire baisser les tensions c'est
comme ça qu'on trouve des solutions
c'est pas en disant à l'autre bout je
veux dire comment faire les choses au
niveau politique
est-ce que 1 va trop lentement et l'eau
trop rapidement encore une fois c'est
une excellente question moi comme avocat
j'ai pas nécessairement une opinion
politique sur la chambre ce que je peux
vous dire par contre c'est que leur
conférera devant les tribunaux lorsque
les acteurs choisissent d'aller dans les
techniques pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée la cause des tea party wasquehal
auxerre a été reconnue c'est une cause
qui a duré plus de vingt ans et qui
coûtait 31 millions $ dans 19 millions
pour les autres acteurs alors on
s'entend que pour des chefs héréditaire
et pour des protestataires
cette avenue des tribunaux et est
improbable
alors reste des actions de désobéissance
civile qui leur est alors l'état comment
réagit l'état qui est habitué à des
contestations judiciaires qui moins
habitués et tolérants face à la
désobéissance civile
surtout lorsque des intérêts économiques
qui sont en jeu qui peuvent affecter le
fonds appelle l'intérêt national
en plus de l'arrêt
la population en général l'état
normalement vaut réagir de façon forte
parce que l'état détient le monopole de
la violence et de l'ordre et il va
vouloir rétablir cet ordre là d'un autre
côté les tribunaux ont dit l'omr la
couronne envers les autochtones la
réconciliation passe par le dialogue et
la négociation
alors on se retrouve devant vraiment
deux écoles de pensée par rapport au
rôle de l'état
d'un côté l'état doit maintenir l'ordre
et s'assurer du bon développement
économique et du tra du transport et la
libre circulation des personnes et des
biens et de l'autre côté l'état envers
les autochtones en rôle très spécifique
de réconcilier ces relations et de
trouver des accommodements à leurs
préoccupations et on se retrouve
vraiment devant ces deux philosophies
avec le gouvernement trudeau et d'autre
les provinces et le pose en parti
consommateurs parce que c'est pas tout
l'opposition au fédéral qui est du même
avis préconise la ligne plus dure et
c'est vraiment un affrontement de
philosophie par rapport à la relation
hop
les couronnes et les peuples autochtones
maîtres si jamais l'impasse perdurait on
entend souvent en sciences politiques
que lorsqu'il est question d'intérêt
national
on ne transige pas donc quelque part est
ce qu'on pourrait s'attendre à ce que
dans les prochains jours l'état fasse
appel à la force frappe du poing sur la
table au nom des gros intérêts
économiques qui sont en jeu c'est une
possibilité
et ce qui va falloir mesurer encore une
fois et on en entend de plus en plus
parler c'est que tous les efforts qui
ont été faites par le gouvernement
trudeau depuis 2015 et avant l'heure
quand même que même à l'époque pour
ouvrir le marqueur pour rappeler que ce
gouvernement peut régler la question de
l'épineux dossier des pensionnats c'est
le gouvernement harper qui aurait
autorisé la commission de réconciliation
et de vérité c'est le gouvernement
harper qui
qui a reconnu la déclaration des nations
unies sur les droits temps donc il y
avait déjà un début d'initiatives qui a
été accentuée par le gouvernement
trudeau et les actions qui vont qui vont
être décidées au fil des prochaines
heures ou des prochains jours vont être
déterminantes par rapport à aux efforts
qui ont été déployés par là plusieurs
années et pourrait ramener la situation
à ce qu'elle était il ya quelques
décennies deux heures et ça serait très
dommage d'un autre côté je peux aussi
comprendre la situation dans laquelle
l'état fait face parce que on peut pas
tolérer nécessairement que des actions
de cette cellule a on est dans un état
d' d'état de droit comme on l'appelle de
gloire et de bord et des chemins de fer
ou des routes ni ne sont pas
nécessairement tolérable dans ce
contexte la dernière question j'ai une
question c'est quoi les applications
pour le gouvernement dans une situation
où on a les deux cas les traditionnels
ou les héréditaire avec les autres sons
qui chefs qui sont élus le gouvernement
actuel et tous les gouvernements depuis
l'histoire du canada en fait affaire
avec les conseils élus le système est
basé avec les communications fédéraux
élus des bad élu mais maintenant ils
sont obligés de dire et de faire des
complications avec les chefs et des
éditeurs traditionnels
s'ils commencent à donner le pouvoir
cette groupe là est ce que ça ne risque
pas peut-être de mettre tout les
systèmes en jeu dans le sens que ça va
donner
techniquement l'autorité ou plus
d'autorité à d'autres bandes des chefs
l éditeur tout à fait c'est la raison
pour laquelle quand vous regardez la
situation assez sensible de l'assemblée
des premières nations qui représente
l'ensemble des 635 chef élu la vertu de
la loi sur les indiens
l'arraisonnement et est très prudent
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas appuyer
inconditionnellement des dégâts
qui sont pas des déchets telus des
conseils de bande
donc personne réellement pour le
représenter les intérêts des
gouvernances traditionnelle autochtone
ceci étant dit si vous faire de plus
amples recherches
vous allez voir que iliad et des
politiques de négociation d'autonomie
gouvernementale au niveau du
gouvernement fédéral
il est possible de sortir de la
gouvernance d'une loi sur les indiens et
de négocier une autonomie
gouvernementale qui est qui différentes
mais ça prend évidemment plusieurs
plusieurs années à négocier et il n'y a
pas beaucoup de communautés qui
participent à cette démarche
il existe également des traités moderne
où est ce que il y en a 26 traité
moderne depuis la convention de la baie
james en 1975 et à l'intérieur de ces 26
traiter leurs contenus que la loi sur
les indiens cessent de s'appliquer
il existe une gouvernance légitime et
mis de l'avant et qui est acceptée par
les gouvernements donc il existe des
alternatives mais elles sont très
longues
et elles dépendent énormément dessus de
la volonté du gouvernement fédéral de
conclure des ententes ou non avec
différents formes de gouvernance qui
sont pas nécessairement des conseils
d'avant mais effect l'humain c'est une
question qui demeure très complexe m
nadir andré merci beaucoup d'avoir pris
tout le temps cette semaine de nous
parler et puis nous c'est toujours un
plaisir d'offrir à notre invité
principal
l'occasion de parler d'un sujet pendant
25 minutes c'est pas toujours l'occasion
de le faire comme ça sur nos différentes
antennes donc merci beaucoup merci mais
je vous remercie beaucoup pour le peuple
m'a raccordé n'y a pas grand plaisir
alors c'était m nadir andré qui
travaille pour la firme d'avocats blg à
montréal et fait le tour du canada en
fait le faisait le tour du canada cette
semaine c'est amusant on lui parlait
puis je l'aï rendu au banc durant des
bandes plus que s'accumulent les bons à
tracfin
c'était quelque chose à voir on a encore
de la place pour du plaisir encore
minutes de presser fois d'aller
travailler
vous travaillez en ce moment comme ça
oui c'est comme by partout et ça c'est
très agréable parce que le patron il est
coûteux c'est très très agréable voici
écouter les amis deuxième jeu de la
grosse boule cette semaine combien de
moules à perdre trop trop voilà et puis
a laissé encore toutes ces boules
il me l'avait perdu bien non il n'en a
pas perdu oui j'ai perdu y en a perdu
vous avez éviter de les perdre alors
voici la question ce voile est décrit
comme de personnes experts depuis sept
jours voilà depuis cet article le
service voilà ça sèche pour le reste la
crise
voulez-vous reprendre ça parce que je
vous ai pas j'ai parlé sur vous depuis
sept jours
combien d'articles le service français
de rci at-il produit sur la crise où es
tu souhaites oui alors 7 8 noeuds aucune
de ces réponses
pauvre vous aidez moi à présent engager
parce que vous travaillez pour le
service en anglais vous allez publier
plusieurs projets d'accord le service en
français wils à deux français défie sept
jours depuis sept jours exactement
aucune de ces réponses
aucune de ces réponses seraient confiées
les recettes ce serait un peu près 5 5
ou 6 heures au 6 mai comme vous avez
écrit vous même cinq articles quand même
ce projet écrit cinq bons vous n'en avez
pas fait aucun peut-être deux sets
j'irai avec ça a c'est bien elle se
révise oui j'ai pas ce que vous en avez
fait du respect second segment de
changer des vies
ouais alors vous dites 7 oui j'ai changé
d'idée je persiste et si d'accord et
voudra que je vais 17 au début oui comme
ça comme ça parce qu'injuste sens
chanceux largement 7 1 7 7 chandelles et
des raisins
aujourd'hui on est rendu à cinq avec moi
et deux pour vous remettre aux pensées
vous trois bon on va afficher les bonnes
réponses parce qu'il ya deux bonnes
réponses possibles
9,6 en incluant votre article que vous
avez que vous allez faire vous avez déjà
pu j'ai déjà publié aujourd'hui avant le
début de l'émission juste quelques
secondes avant de presser le bouton pas
blessé bon alors c'est neuf mais en fait
au moment des faits les trois ben oui
faites le compte d'un effet 6 ok j'en ai
fait trois bon d'accord
en fait j'en ai fait deux appuis je
pense dix semaines on a fait un nom il
aura elle n'a pas il n'a pas fait donc
j'en ai fait trois bons doublages ce que
tu vas des fois et avec cette émission
ça fait dix ans elle n'a pas fait non
voilà je vois dans un fossé 8
ouais by nono internautes habitués à
l'abattage probablement plus rapidement
la réponse la bonne réponse que les
musiciens sont alors moi vous avez perdu
30 de leur reste plus que 50
elle voudrait pour le dernier tour de
boules avant de vous présenter le
dernier tour de boules avant de perdre
la boule
j'ai eu le petit je passais je voulais
vous présenter la vérification de la
réponse c'est ce qu'on pouvait voir
cette semaine sur notre site web
d'ailleurs c'est une à 2.6 à qui
accompagne la diffusion de cette
émission de temps canada donc si je
pense notre vidéo numéro voilà la vidéo
blanche
voilà c'est tout les articles qu'on ait
un article publié sur ces questions là
vous allez vous a vu en écriture oui
tout à fait les réactions politiques et
la mobilisation qui ne désemplit pas sur
le terrain il ne manque à votre article
dessus de tout à l'heure jallet du
blocus à saint lambert
ouais ou les manifestants continuent à
défier les forces de l'ordre très bien
voilà donc tout le monde est sur
l'expectative
en attendant de voir ce que ça va donner
est-ce que la grc 20 heures la saq va
intervenir ou c'est joli c'est l'oral la
police de longueuil qui va intervenir
d'où le fait que le premier ministre
québécois expriment assez facilement ce
genre de questions parce qu'il a pris la
parole tout à l'heure au dire que tout
était entre les mains des policiers de
longueuil et qu'il pouvait intervenir à
tout moment
incessamment d'accord écoutez on est
prêts pour notre troisième jeu oui on va
par la boule parce que à les y voilà
on va fait se pose mais on est prêt pour
le dernier jeu 50 boules à perdre on va
afficher la question pour le plaisir
tous et chacun la première nation
watchou et n compte combien d'habitants
selon vous combien d'habitants au niveau
de la première nation web souhaitait bon
s'ils sont pas si nombreux que ça 3450
ça me semble pas très bien d'ailleurs
j'ai lu à la casse est très nombreux
2800 2008 ça moi je la vendrai cette
réponse c'est environ environ avait
environ b environ ses environs t environ
à environ 11 ans paraît nombreux ouais
vous avez tous raison vous avez conservé
malheureusement moi je pensais que
j'allais vous coulez à l'examen ah oui
c'est qu à quoi ça ressemble et journée
ce bien informée félicitations on
apprend des choses
les bretons démissionne et en écoutant
aussi l'actualité sur ce sujet là parce
qu'ils en ont beaucoup parlé
donc si des gens qui sont pas très
nombreux mais qui sont par ailleurs très
très déterminée par rapport à leur cause
donc et poursuivre la mobilisation et
les chefs les chefs et l'éditeur il se
trouve du côté de l'est canadien où il
entend de se rencontrer la communauté
moi ok pour les remercier hockey appuis
au québec et en ontario parce que mon
interview du côté de belleville je crois
oui ils ont rencontré des gens c'est que
les gens qui les appuient les puits
pendant qu'ils faisaient de la sna ils
ont pas le temps d'aller parler aux pays
bas il sait jean rozé ils ont posé des
conditions à cela parmi lesquels le
retrait de la grc de leur terme
tout le monde voilà donc et pour le
moment ils sont pas prêts à négocier
d'autant que certaines de ces conditions
là ne sont pas respectées c'est bien je
comprends très bien ce qui se passe
merci grand samuel fortier grâce
évidemment l'activité spatiale et vous
avez une méchante de bonnes questions à
la fin si on commence à négocier avec
des chefs de telle nation que va t-il se
refuse en soit on a loué jusqu'où
peut-on aller quand on veut redéfinir va
bien finir ce système au complet c'est
facile de le jeunesse de poser des
questions et c'est très difficile pour
les politiciens d'y répondre
je trouve qu'on a le beau rôle karman
un peu facile notre affaire on est prêt
pour l'image de la semaine qui est
toujours notre événement bucolique où on
vous présente quelque chose sans trop
vraiment avoir le sentiment de devoir
tout expliquer puisque c'est l'image la
semaine c'est ce dont tout le monde
parle en ce moment mais cette semaine
leur exception c'est pas toujours cette
crise là non c'est non c'est pas de
crise là l'image de la semaine à cette
fin que ça c'est quelque chose de
différent du show des principales
émissions
moi je réponds pas par des indices je
réponds par ou par manque elle est
l'image de la semaine cette semaine
louis telle est l'image c'est non
réponse est non à les convier à une
autre question très sagement va mettre
contre l' ingérence l'image de semaine
oui allez-y questions sur 12 est-ce que
c'est minéral végétal ou à les poser des
questions politiques politique qui
attend dé voir politique
oui il ya un aspect très politique à
tout cela oui oui oui cette réunion à
laquelle angie a été exclu non non pas
aussi politique que ça c est ce que
c'est lié avec les autochtones non ça
n'a rien à voir avec cet acteur est ce
que ça dit avec la maltraitance animale
c'est lié avec que ben non pas neeman
s'est situé à nantes à lyon ouais c'est
en ontario au whist ontario mais je le
sers à massifs tels des enseignants non
ça aurait pu être sa lame nf c est ce
que ça concerne les automobiles non
s'effondrent les automobiles ça concerne
un avion puis des autobus
ouais ça c'est un méchant th17 virus oui
madame
les canadiennes qui sont de retour à la
maison
voilà représentent les images l'image de
la sema louis gassée des images
mouvantes c'est l'avion qui a priori à
la base militaire ce matin à peu près
200 canadiens parce qu'on sait qui a 47
qui sont restés sur place à tokyo
recevoir des soins
alors après vérification médicale on les
met à bord d'autobus et voici le premier
qui arrive à sepang base militaire même
si les voir des militaires c'est un
centre hôtelier de conférences en banque
en bordure de couloirs de petites villes
comme moi je connais bien puisque je me
trouve
ma maison est à 7 km de la neige un jet
de pierre de là bas un jet de 20 dollars
il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes à corps
noir les mêmes vous ne l'avez appris
quelque chose
oui j'ai vu du côté de l'ukraine un
autobus qui a reçu des pierres un
autobus qui transportait en israël en
ukraine certaines de ces personnes n'ont
pas au canada alors ils sont accueillis
vous allez voir par des militaires il y
a ils ont les voit pas beaucoup parce
que je pense qu'on veut respecter lors
un leur vie privée vous allez le voir
mais donc des personnes qui vont rester
en confinement pendant dix-sept avec
avec les personnes qui arrivent de la
fée dehors du japon
donc le temps de voir si ces personnes
là ne sont pas touchés par quatorze
jours de fer vitesse je pense que la
datation dix autres qui sont arrivés il
y a deux semaines comme ancêtre à partir
partir de l'autre c'est une base
militaire de trenton
là ils sont un coin de voile à la
napster qui modèle fédéral pour des
comme je vous dis tu sentais conférence
est toujours anciennement je pense que
c'est pour le code de la garde côtière
c'était pour vous former des gens à
l'aviation aviation and have center
centre de navigation
vous avez peut-être raison soutient que
c'était maritime moi je vous raconte ça
c'est juste à côté du fleuve pour y
tirer une roche là et c'est pour ça
qu'on grandit pas encore s'ils arrivent
à l'index abondé fleurance et par
l'actualité c'est ce désir rocher où le
plus gros le problème avec des nouveaux
des nouvelles plaques d'automobiles
d'intalio qu'on ne voit pas en voir y
est on sait pas c'est quoi le numéro de
la plaque arrière et policiers se sont
plaints g a dit on va remettre cet
automne ce cas toute la lumière on voit
absolument mais c'est bon pour les gens
qui quittent et passe les vitesses et
les caméras automatiques nous ne peut
pas prendre les photos vous entendez la
musique
c'est nous perdons le satellite dans
cette seconde à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
à